it's still one of the great rivalries in
the national football league the atlanta
falcons and new orleans saints even
though the falcons
aren't very good this year that rivalry
got far more intriguing with the news
that drew brees will miss sunday's game
likely we'll miss the rematch in just
two weeks and we don't know what will
happen in the absence of breeze joining
us now to help us make sense of what the
saints may or may not be doing on sunday
when the falcons come to town is cat
terrell of the athletics she covers the
saints for that publication cat good
afternoon how are you
doing great how about y'all
oh we're doing great we appreciate some
of your time
um
how strange has the week been given sean
payton's obsession with keeping from
anyone and everyone what actually is
happening and what actually will occur
come sunday
well thankfully i've been through this
rodeo before having covered this
since 2012. so i'm well used i'm well
versed in the sean payton injury
weirdness um this week was probably up
there though because we did not get to
talk to a single quarterback
um didn't get told who we were talking
to until like five minutes before
interviews started i mean that's how
much he did not want
falcons to know
who was going to be starting this week
um it kind of made me laugh because uh
someone mentioned you know there's a
report that taysom hill is starting he
said he hadn't seen that if you know
sean payton he's seen it
but you know it all indications are that
it's going to be taysom hill and hey i'm
excited i just like anyone else i don't
know what this guy can do so i mean i'm
really looking forward to this game
doesn't it make it easier for peyton to
keep it all kind of vague and amorphous
and ambiguous because of the covet 19
rules because you can't get into the
locker room and maybe pull someone aside
or maybe somebody let something slip
you're only getting a small handful of
access to coaches to players and it's a
different kind of sanitary environment
where you're talking into a camera
there's no opportunity for off the
record none of the normal things we
would see doesn't that make it easier
for them to to keep it all under wraps
i think so i mean peyton more than
anyone knows that these things get out
he's been doing this forever but i think
he'd much rather get out on friday than
a wednesday and coaches always worry
about that stuff they worry that we'll
go up to someone in the locker room and
they'll let something slip just like you
said and it makes it a lot easier for
the team to contain that when the
players are just staring into a computer
screen and they're not
and you know kind of a relaxed
environment where they might
accidentally say who's starting so yeah
i mean that definitely works in their
favor this week
cat after going on ir obviously drew
brees is going to miss at least three
games and he missed five last year and
they went 5-0 without him do you feel as
confident about this year's team that
they can continue to operate at that
level continue to win games without drew
brees
i think they can i did predict them to
lose this week just because i think
despite the fact that they've been on a
roll i think the falcons are catching
them at a good time where the falcons
are playing a lot better than they were
the saints are dealing with a lot of
injuries plus the unknown of starting a
court or likely starting a quarterback
we don't know much about
but i think they can win without him do
i still think they need him yes but i
think that this team has kind of gotten
to a level where they've shown they can
win in all three phases of the game they
have very good special teams units
defense has been a little erratic this
year but they have shown when they put
it together they are a very good defense
so they're capable of it so yes they can
win without him but they do have some
tough games coming up luckily for them
it's right at that mark where he might
be coming back they have the chiefs in a
month they have the vikings on christmas
day so he could be back by then
cat what's been the vibe around the team
in recent years with taysom hill being a
jack of all trades and now in a position
to be the quarterback we know how sean
payton feels about him we've seen what
he can do he's getting a lot of money
some would say that maybe they're
overpaying it because they don't use
them as much as they should what do the
teammates think about taysom hill
well i think any time
you have a player that shows up and
consistently has this ability to make
the big plays on game days that people
respect that
you against the vikings most of the team
was struggling last year in the playoffs
no one really did much of anything and
then you take taysom hill and he's
ripping off these big yardage canes and
he had that huge throat to deontay
harris and
he hasn't done as much this year but he
is a guy that has his ability just to
turn it up on game days and i think his
teammates are looking forward to you
know seeing what he can do um as an
actual quarterback maybe
i mean they've obviously seen more in
practice than we have but
i don't think even they truly know what
they're gonna get this weekend but i
mean i do think that his teammates are
very supportive of him and behind him
especially drew brees i mean he and
breeds have a great relationship and
have for a while
we know that taysom has had limited
chances at quarterback in the nfl and
and jameis has a lot of experience he
threw over 5 000 yards last season 33
touchdowns
what are the chances kat that we see
both of these quarterbacks on sunday or
moving forward beyond this week
i think this week going off of the
assumption and reports and everything
that it's take some i think that we only
see taysom
going forward i don't know because what
if this ends in disaster and they have
to go back to winston or what if they're
thinking of a way to involve both of
them i don't really see a two
quarterback system going forward to be
completely honest i just think that they
would be too concerned about what would
happen if one of them gets hurt and then
they they don't have a third quarterback
on the roster right now that could
change with breeze going on ir but even
if it does it would be someone who's
just coming in off the street
so right now i think it's kind of taysom
hill's audition you see what you do with
this and then we go forward from there
um but
it's really intriguing just because
they're so different but there's so
little we we
know about taysom
and we've seen so much of jamis so it's
it's kind of like a wild card i did
watch both of them in training camp and
i actually thought that winston had the
better training camp i mean i thought he
was going to be the backup coming out
but you still saw those problems with
winston that kind of dogged him his
entire career and you even saw last week
he just has his tendency to he shows off
his huge
arm but he also does that by
overthrowing receivers or making bad
decisions and um hill is just you know
really different he's more likely to run
the ball if something goes wrong then to
maybe force it
into double or triple coverage so
they're both kind of fascinating unique
quarterbacks and so different than bruce
there's been an assumption in some
circles that this is going to be drew
brees final season i remember sean
payton
had a misstatement that he had to try to
clean up in the off season that this is
drew's last year what's the the vibe
among the folks who cover the team is
this it for drew or is there a chance
he's back next year
i think the general consensus is that
this is it and most of us felt that way
going into the season uh just all the
hints uh bree's taking longer than
normal to announce he's coming back um
brie is just talking about how this is
hard on his family you know everyone
thinks that when a quarterback gets
older and it's been in the league
forever that it's easier for them
because they don't have to work as hard
well in reality it's actually the
opposite because you know as their
bodies break down they have to work even
harder and recovery and treatment and
things like that and making sure that
they can get through game day well now
we're getting to a point where the last
two years
breeze's body has kind of
shown that maybe it's wearing down i
mean i know the thumb injury could have
happened to anyone but this accumulation
of the rib injuries and the shoulder
injury and all the hits he's taken um
all 43 of them this year i counted
i just think that it's probably all a
way
of saying or all signs pointing towards
this is the end
but he does awesome
awesome stuff we appreciate some of your
time we'll check out your work at the
athletic and we hope to talk to you
again down the road
thanks for having me on thanks kat all
right there she is cat terrell of the
athletic when we return
our weekly feature what can't we wait to
see when sunday rolls around we'll do
that when pftp continues right after
this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports